[Musique]
principaux boum du recyclage dans le
pays la jeune entreprise dont il est le
directeur à trouver un filon porteur
transformer ses déchets en granulés qui
vont servir à la fabrication du nouveau
produit industriels nous avons à peu
près 450 personnes qui collecte pour
nous donc qui collecte et qui vient de
revendre leur plastique en Amérique le
but de tout ça c'est de permettre à tous
les plastiques preneurs à tous nos
collecteurs à tout ce qui vivent de
plastique de pouvoir s'en sortir à 20 km
de là l'usine que j'ai à Chris ma Biala
où arrive chaque jour une dizaine de
tonnes de déchets collectés à travers le
pays il y a zéro déchet c'est ça non ici
commence une seconde vie pour le
plastique collecté priez nettoyer il est
ensuite broyé par ces énormes machines
jusqu'à l'obtention de granulés
décannelés qui vont être exportés en
Europe pour la fabrication des produits
distribués principalement aux sociétés
praticales
chaque année 3000 tonnes de déchets sont
ainsi recyclés
et d'autre part
la fabrication et la la vente de nos
produits finis nous souhaitons voir tout
le monde impliquer dans les défis que
nous pose le problème de la pollution
plastique le recyclage du plastique un
marché qui attire les entrepreneurs dans
la capitale économique camerounaise
alors que les prix des matériaux de
construction s'envolent avec l'inflation
mondiale le plastique recyclé est devenu
une alternative sur les chantiers de BTP
ça passe bien enchanté cette huile bleue
sont ainsi fabriqués à base de déchets
plastiques Claude cepono commercialise
ce matériau transformer localement qui
coûte bien moins cher que des tuiles
importées du Turquie ou d'Italie soit 20
euros le mètre carré au lieu de 28 €
pour une seule tuile importée sur le
marché vous avez l'étude en ciment qui
se casse vous avez les tuiles en a
importé de l'Italie qui se casse et vous
avez cette huile c'est ça la solution
durable
de couverture qu'on peut avoir ça se
pose comme le carreau au fur et à mesure
ensuite juste la coupe d'achapante et on
réalise la toiture dans l'usine qui
produit cette huile bleue un plastique
lourd le polymère est combiné à du sable
et chauffer il y a 220 degrés le mélange
est ensuite moulé pour fabriquer ce
revêtement pour toiture qui pourrait
concurrencer les tôles en aluminium
encore très utilisés
à une durée de vie de 30 ans par contre
la turque nous produisons à une durée de
vie qu'on ne peut pas mesurer c'est à
dire que c'est à vie l'avantage du
produit c'est quoi nous avons
l'isolation thermique donc en dessous de
cette huile vous avez une température
vraiment ambiante vous savez l'isolation
phonique c'est-à-dire que quand il pleut
le son depuis vous ne les ressentez pas
si certains recycle le plastique pour
fabriquer des matières isolantes
d'autres entrepreneurs en temps de faire
baisser la facture énergétique grâce aux
déchets en fabriquant par exemple un
carburant moins cher
dans le hangar de cette villa en
construction Walter jackia teste sa
dernière trouvaille un carburant à base
de plastique recyclés
grâce à cette machine qu'il a fabriqué
avec son équipe ce chef d'entreprise de
40 ans travaille depuis des années à la
production d'un carburant moins polluant
pour l'instant il n'en produit que de
petites quantités mais asper bientôt
proposer aux consommateurs un carburant
plus respectueux de l'environnement à
moindre coût aujourd'hui il nous aide
quand même à amortir pratiquement 15% de
notre consommation de carburant un
carburant écologique qui vous coûtera
dans les 350 francs alors qu'à la
station service vous avez le même litre
qui va vous coûter 650 fois demain nous
pouvons produire 10000 et voir même plus
par jour 10000 litres par jour pourquoi
pas donc à ce moment nous pouvons nous
envisageons de pouvoir
commercialiser un grand échelle le
Cameroun produit en moyenne 600000
tonnes de déchets plastiques chaque
année
et bien que les entreprises de recyclage
soient de plus en plus nombreuses seul
20% de ses déchets sont traités